Heidi Klum and Padma Lakshmi's show off  their enviable ads are you ready for  this  palma posted at this big rockin summit  sexy underwear the top chef host  captioned the shot don't hate because  i'm in lingerie moms do that sometimes  very comfortable then there's Heidi she  took us behind the scenes of a new photo  shoot for her intimates line on  Instagram we see Heidi frolicking in the  water  whipping her hair and hang in with the  krill it's a lot of fun obviously the  supermodel is pretty fearless when it  comes to flaunting her figure she even  went topless a few weeks back I gotta  ask you the Heidi Klum bikini line it  does come a tops right Heidi it comes  with a yes it does come with tops but  you know I'm a European German girl and  we like to go topless have a little fun  don't love the tan lines  you